first thing i want to talk about today
is student loans everyone wants to
cancel student loans this has become the
topic
of conversation every politician in
america continues to promise that we're
going to cancel student loans this is
the dumbest idea in the world guess why
the way a student loan works is you say
i want to go to college i want to go
spend two or four years i want to get a
piece of paper to show some corporation
that i'm a genius i did the work and
they should hire me and so ultimately
what you're doing is you're going for
one of three reasons you're either going
because you want to get the validation
and get the stamp of approval of college
or you're going because you actually
want to learn the knowledge or you're
going because you just want to party
your face off and get the social scene i
actually think one of the strongest
reasons why people should still go to
college is because the people you meet
end up being a huge benefit to you if
you go to a good school over the long
portion of your career but if you're not
just going for social reasons you're
either going to get a piece of paper or
you're going to learn most people would
argue that they actually didn't learn
that much in college they got the piece
of paper that was the most valuable
piece or they made relationships that
was a valuable piece as well so in order
to go get a piece of paper or go make
some friends there's lots and lots of
people who have been convinced that they
should take out ten thousand dollars of
student debt all the way up to some
people have 200 250 000 of student debt
and depending on whether you think
that's a good idea or not ends up being
besides the point but people have taken
on incredible levels of student debt and
the student debt isn't like normal debt
this is debt that in many cases uh you
can't get rid of no matter what happens
you could literally file for bankruptcy
personally and you still cannot get rid
of the debt they own you you are going
to pay back the money and it doesn't
matter if it takes you one year or it
takes you three decades they're going to
get their money and so the reason why
this ends up being a huge problem is
because guess what news flash if you
went and got a philosophy degree and had
to borrow 160 000 to do it and then you
try to use your philosophy degree to get
a job you're probably not going to make
enough money to pay off your 160 000
worth of debt that's a problem on top of
that if you went you got an art history
degree and you don't go and work at the
highest levels of the art history market
you're probably not going to be able to
pay off your debt and so naturally what
happens is there's tons and tons of
people who didn't go get quote unquote
real degrees in math or science or
engineering or something that would end
up providing them a high degree of
income in the medical field and law or
somewhere else instead what they did is
they went and they got a degree that's
basically useless it was more so to
check off a box that either their
parents forced on them uh their uh their
parents friends or they thought society
was gonna need guess what after you're
at the age of like i don't know 25 26 no
one asked you where you went to school
anymore nobody cares they want to know
can you do the job so this whole sham
that's been going on in the world it's
been going on for quite a while and it's
fine that's how the world has worked uh
but the fact that student debt is now
over 1.5 trillion dollars in the united
states is absolutely absurd and you
can't get rid of the debt it stuck with
you so now here come the genius
politicians and what the politicians say
they say they're going to go ahead and
they're going to get rid of all student
debt sounds great it's like the perfect
thing to campaign on oh you owe a bunch
of money i'm just gonna get that wiped
away vote for me it's kind of like when
you're in high school and the student
body president wants to run for office
become the student body president and
what do they say i'll give you a
lollipop of you vote for me that's all
politicians are doing they just now are
doing the adult version of they don't
give you a lollipop they said they're
gonna wipe out your student debt don't
be an idiot in high school and fall for
the lollipop don't be an idiot as an
adult and fall for empty promises
why is canceling student debt not
actually possible there is no cancelling
of debt all they are saying is not we're
going to cancel student debt what
they're saying is we're going to make
somebody else pay for the debt the debt
still gets paid for it just gets
offloaded somewhere else and so whether
it ends up being wealthy people whether
it ends up being the corporations that
actually extended some of the student
debt or it ends up getting passed on to
you as an individual via things like
inflation devaluation of the currency
etc some form or fashion somebody in the
world is going to pay for that debt
and it ends up sending the wrong message
if we have people who are 18 years old
who are making decisions they're legally
considered an adult
in the court of law if they end up
making a decision to take on this debt
and then we later come back to them and
say hey by the way we know every person
whoever came before you who took on this
debt they had to pay it back they worked
their asses off they made sacrifices but
they paid off the debt they lived up to
their responsibility and they fulfilled
those responsibilities but now you you
young millennial kids oh we feel bad for
you guys you guys shouldn't have such a
tough life you guys really need a
helping hand we're gonna wipe out all
this student debt well guess what that
just makes people soft it literally just
means the next time that they get in a
crisis the next time they get in some
kind of hard time they're going to turn
to the government they're going to say
help me help me help me you wiped out my
student debt oh now i'm underwater on my
mortgage can you help me there oh i'm at
my job and uh they're not paying me
enough money instead of going and doing
the hard work to find another job like
just send me a check i can't wait for
ubi it'd be amazing
it sends the wrong message ends up
teaching young people that they do not
have to live up to their
responsibilities now on top of that even
more ridiculously is that actually it's
similar to when they sent the free
checks during covet remember when the
government came out and they said oh
people are suffering we need to help and
they went ahead and they printed all
this money trillions of dollars and they
handed out checks directly to
individuals literally we had
billionaires going on cnbc saying i'm a
billionaire how come i got a 1200 check
that's crazy well it's because the
government was in charge of the program
and they ended up being highly
inefficient it's now estimated that
nearly half of the ppp money ended up
actually being given to criminals
nefarious actors and people in foreign
countries
pretty wasteful but what ended up
occurring is they sold the dream they
said we're gonna give you twelve hundred
dollars it's gonna be amazing we're just
literally sending tens of millions of
american households and if you give
people free money what do they say i'll
take it whether they should or not they
don't know any better they say i'll take
the free money and when the government
went ahead and gave them 1200
what ended up occurring was that we got
eight and a half percent inflation
40-year high inflation you can't print
trillions of dollars stuff in every
exotic corner of the financial system
and not have some sort of blowback i saw
a tweet yesterday that absolutely had me
cracking up they said well the
government printed seven trillion
dollars and they got negative 1.4 gdp
growth and so ultimately what we are
watching is this is a complete failure
of monetary and fiscal policy all of the
undisciplined policy that's been put in
place over the last two years it finally
we got the report card f minus literally
none of it worked it had the opposite
effect because those twelve hundred
dollars that they ended up giving to
people would you rather get twelve
hundred dollars one time or would you
rather pay on average according to the
official government numbers eight and a
half percent more for all of your goods
well of course you would rather not have
to pay more uh eight and a half percent
more for all of those goods you would
much rather just say i don't need the
1200 bucks the trade-off's not worth it
but just like i and many other people
were saying for now literally two years
is this was gonna happen this was always
going to happen you cannot put trillions
of dollars into the financial system and
not expect prices to go up the price of
investments went up stock market was up
30 bitcoin was up 65 last year et cetera
real estate's up 20 or so across
different markets and
things like gasoline food electricity
etc in a consumable space those are all
up as well with the average cpi reading
of 8.5 percent now the real inflation
rate is probably in the mid teens but
they're not going to tell you that
because they're going to continue to
manipulate that cpi number to make it
seem like it's oh it's only eight and a
half percent it's only a 40-year high no
it's probably somewhere closer to like
15 which is pretty insane and so
ultimately giving relief on student debt
ends up being the exact same thing if
they go ahead and actually cancel
student debt it will cause prices to go
up it will cause more inflation it will
offload the responsibility of those with
student debt to somebody else this is
literally like if you took out a piece
of paper and you said what is one of the
dumbest policies we could come up with
you wrote it down this would be near the
top of the list
if you teach people that they do not
have to live up to their
responsibilities it ends up creating
more long-term problems if you also on
top of that then say hey we are going to
relieve over a trillion dollars of debt
from the system
the value has to come from somewhere so
what you end up doing is you
you start to try to minimize or mitigate
short-term problems which are really
just a small portion of people who have
the student debt for the cost of
long-term problems this exactly happened
during the pandemic when there's the
liquidity crisis in march of 2020 what'd
they do they ran in they did two
emergency rate cuts got the interest
rate down to zero they pumped trillions
of dollars into the economy and they
mitigated short-term pain that is what
the incentive system is for politicians
and central bankers they don't care what
happens in 10 years they probably aren't
even going to be in office then all they
care about is right now how do i get
elected next cycle and so because they
mitigated that short-term pain it was at
the cost of the long-term pain was it
worth it i don't know it's hard to
calculate but now we have eight and a
half percent official inflation and what
we're seeing is that there are more
americans today that are in a worse
financial position than they were just
two years ago why well 45 of americans
have no investable assets they are
literally poorer today than they were
two years ago because about 40 of all
dollars in circulation have been printed
in the last two years and when you then
start to layer in the fact that oh
remember that stock market that everyone
was cheering about it was up so much and
of course that was padding the
impact of inflation well it's not really
up that much anymore and so ultimately
it ends up being a really really big
problem so canceling student debt is
stupid any politician who's trying to
tell you about it
is literally pandering looking for votes
or they are a complete idiot and they
don't understand economics many of them
check both boxes they're pandering and
don't know anything about economics and
so what you at home need to do is you
need to be intelligent need to be
informed need to understand that you
cannot cancel student debt if you cancel
the student debt all they are doing it's
an election year they're looking for
votes or they are going to end up
screwing you because they're going to
increase inflation they're going to
increase costs somewhere else they're
going to offload the responsibility and
the burden from individuals that have
the student debt today remember these
are supposedly adults now of course the
male brains not actually fully developed
till 25 so the fact that we let 18 year
olds take out hundreds of thousands of
debt to go get an imaginary piece of
paper or to make friends is insane but
even though we allow them to do that we
claim in the legal court they're an
adult now we're gonna come in and you
know the government i am here from the
government i am here to save you well
that's probably not a good idea never
worked out in the past so i don't think
this is a good idea i actually think it
won't happen uh but as you know more and
more crazy things are happening in the
world and so we'll see how this plays
out hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time